we have to keep in mind not only the
places you mentioned but southeast Asia
for the most part is not Democratic yet
it is essentially pro-western
pro-american anti-chinese there's change
now a foot in Thailand of course but
generally Southeast a Asia has pockets
of it that are not Democratic and uh so
the world does not neatly divide you
know I was a forign correspondent for
decades and what I saw was not a black
and white situation of great democracies
and terrible dictatorships I saw a lot
of Gray Shades a lot of dictatorships
where people had civil rights where
people had predictable decent lives and
I also saw some shambolic you know
totally unstable democracies um and I
think that one mistake that the Biden
Administration has made in Ukraine
though generally I think their policy
has been pretty good we could talk about
that maybe but one mistake they've made
is to you know make it a contest of
democracy versus
authoritarianism because um uh it should
be something even bigger it should just
be hold upholding some sort of rules
based order where a big country cannot
just physically attack another you know
reasonably sized country you know with
with massive weapons and human rights
violations and everyone would just get
you know accept it you know remember
when James Baker um you know came up
with like a 34 Nation coalition to
oppose uh Iraq's occupation of Kuwait
most of those countries were not
democracies and Baker didn't care um
because Baker was more interested in
reconciliations rather than giving
ultimatums I mean what can see that a a
kind of um monotonic uh insistence on
this is democracy versus autocracy it's
going to alienate a lot of a lot of
powers in in the in the first place and
it looks like a way of the US or the
west or Europe re trying to reclaim a
sort of global Primacy that it's already
lost I mean well already I mean one of
the things that strikes me is um uh a
multipolar world isn't a dark put inist
plot we're already in one it's just a
fact yeah it's what it's what we do with
it uh is what the How the West um adapts
to it which is uh which is key and so
insisting on this Democratic democracy
versus authoritarian it it it blinds one
to the real power power relations I mean
I think by the way I thought that the
reemergence of um Assad in the the
Middle East recently as a sort of
credible almost respectable figure was a
warning in some sense which is that um
the the notion that one can attempt to
intervene as the West
did in a very complicated uh internal
struggle of the kind that went on in
Syria fail and leave it doesn't it it
does have long-term consequences the
long-term consequences were that Russia
entered the vacuum and kept its client
in power and he's still there can you
envisage a situation in which let's
think of a kind of a dark scenario could
there be a situation five years from now
in which Putin was in that in a similar
position it's not impossible is it yeah
I think you know that gets us into into
two subjects the difference between the
Middle East and Europe now Europe you
know because Europe has all the building
blocks of democracy it's got middle
classes it's got you know a long long
tradition of parliamentarianism the few
countries in Europe that are not
democracies like bellus and Russia
are you know are devastating failures um
so I think over the next few months
we're about to see a fork in the road in
Europe whereby if the ukrainians really
do well on the battlefield over the next
few weeks and months um we're going to
see a know you know a lot of
triumphalism about the success of
democracy and that will be true for
Europe um but it but it does not carry
over into the Middle East or other parts
of the world as we saw at the end of the
Cold War when because Poland became free
people started to say therefore Liberia
and sier Leon will be free you know and
there was no connection so there were a
lot of dashed hopes in the 1990s because
people thought you know we had reached
the end of history in 1989 I think
something similar might evolve now
because I do think the ukrainians are
going to do very very well on the
battlefield in the next few
months I I a different analogy I would
make is I remember having conversations
with people in uh the runup two and then
the immediate aftermath of the Iraq War
in which some of them mostly from the
United States said look well we were
able
to uh have Democratic regimes in former
Nazi Germany and for former militarist
Japan so we can in Iraq and what I said
at that time was however terrible and
indeed it was uniquely terrible Nazi
Germany was there was still a civil
society underneath there they'd been in
power for 13 years not 30 years they've
done colossal and unique and irreparable
harms but there was still there were
still institutions that could be
remerged and that was also true actually
of Japan the first nonwestern country to
industrialize uh that there were there
were a couple of generations there so
the idea that what might work in if if
if the ukrainians do do as
well as uh um you suggest they will in
the next few months the kind of
triumphalism even if the triumphalism
reverberates successfully in Europe
you're quite right it will not
reverberate successfully in the Middle
East or in Africa or the other parts of
the world yes because um you know just
look at Sudan now we had at least the
first round disappointment in elections
in
Turkey um so that you know it's a matter
of you know Germany Japan you know you
know uh uh you know at the end of World
War II were completely defeated yes
devastated societet occupied and
occupied and occupied and nevertheless
had the building blocks of middle class
existence um and they didn't have great
ethnic splits or anything like that so
they were perfect and also the American
public was willing to underwrite a vast
democracy building project in those
countries because they had just fought a
war over it essentially you know a mass
conscription War but those things don't
they just do not obtain and a further
thing that doesn't obtain which is that
even though is weak in many ways it's
expanding in parts of Africa yes I mean
at least or at least proxies of it or
expressions of it the V are expanding
into Mali where the French were yes so
actually in some parts of the world it's
still an expanding
presence yes I'd like to bring up
something John that you you had uh
written in the new Statesman I think
that this you know this um indicting
Putin as a war criminal uh in the hay
is a very interesting event because as
you put it it sort of
presupposes that there will be a post
Putin Russia and it will be
benign um but that's a lot to assume it
is I mean you know obviously there will
someday be a post Putin Russia you know
maybe sooner rather than later we don't
know but the idea that Russia will
somehow be more benign after Putin or
easier to deal with well that's a
possibility a strong Poss possibility
but it may not be a probability no I
don't think it is I mean we're in a
realm which is so uncertain that
probabilities even don't apply it's real
uncertainty but I see no reason to
suppose that Russia might not either uh
um shrink into a radical nationalist
Russia led by someone perhaps even less
rational and even more dangerous than
Putin has proved to be or break up
altogether
uh like it did in uh when the zor Empire
collapsed uh as a result partly of the
first world war when at one point I
think there were 13 separate state-like
entities in Russia and somewhere around
10 or 12 million people died in the
following in the wars plague famines and
so on and so forth so the assumption
that um uh he can be tried with a kind
of a benign Russia in the background uh
which approves of this trial and doesn't
see it as yet another humiliation or
another defeat is a big
assumption yeah um you know I I think
one thing we should keep our eye on is I
said earlier that I think the ukrainians
are going to do very well on the
battlefield over the next few weeks and
months um if they're able to seriously
fundamentally threaten Crimea absolutely
I think Putin could be in a lot of
trouble because crime cria is not
eastern Ukraine Crimea you know has
associations with Catherine the Great it
goes back to Russian historical
Romanticism um if Putin is seen to be
the cause of potentially losing crimeia
that could cause a real um you know a
real power struggle of some even go to
my knowledge even gorbachov and until
recently even
Nali did not argue for for giving back
Crimea to Ukraine they see that as sanit
and as huge numbers of Russian
intellectuals and thinkers have seen it
as actually uh a foundational part in
geopolitical terms the port and so on
but as part of as part of Russia I think
if really Crimea looks seriously in
question then the balloon goes up that's
the risk not only is put Putin at risk
if Putin's at risk then will he take it
lying down or will he throw the dice
again we don't know do we no no we don't
know I think one thing we should say um
you know because the title of this
program is the age of tragedy or some
sort um is what we mean by tragedy yes
and by tragedy doesn't mean that we're
pessimists um what means that you know
because uh because disappointment and
failure is the normal rule of life in
any case that's not what the Greeks
meant by tra
what the Greeks really meant was a world
of tough choices where you know where
the world is inherently imperfect yet at
the same time it is beautiful um and
tragedy means you know making decisions
between two goods you can only choose
one good over another good but whatever
you choose will cause suffering in some
quarter um and therefore an age of
tragedy just mean means uh you know an
age where things will not be perfect
where we can't always get what we want
all the time that you know that we'll
have to choose between um giving in to
authoritarianism and or you know and and
demanding perfect Democratic outcomes
because we shouldn't give in
authoritarianism but at the same time
we're not going to be able to demand in
every case perfect Democratic outcomes I
I agree with that Holy and I think
that's something that we could uh uh
talk a little more about I'd put it
perhaps very similarly to the way you
put it Robert but maybe um slightly even
more strongly I would say uh when we
talk of tragedy in geopolitics or
elsewhere we're not just talking about
imperfect ability we're not just talking
about the intermittent or reversible
character of progress we're not just
talking about why that history hasn't
ended if you go back to the Greeks and
uh and later to to Shakespeare and other
writers of tragic drama what we're
talking about is that um there are
recurrent situations in the human world
in which whatever is chosen involves
irreparable
loss yeah May those choices may be Noble
they may be uh
heroic sometimes often are uh uh they
may they may activate the most um
valuable and AD features of human beings
of human agency but they involve
irreparable loss so the idea that we
would eventually get to some point in
World politics or human society in which
there was no tragedy would mean that
these conflicting values would somehow
all be harmonized but that's not the way
the human world is and it's certainly
not the way geopolitics is so uh but I
think that's entirely consistent with
with what you've said because what it
means is um we can't say we won't
support that because it doesn't involve
a perfectly Democratic outcome we won't
support that because it involves
legitimating some kind of Injustice and
that's why I think I'm rather maybe
slightly more skeptical than you are of
a legalistic model of international
relations because if we say well this
regime or this leader has committed
crimes can't ever do a deal with him
he's got to go to the to a court I think
that actually makes um conflict
potentially more devastating than it
could otherwise be uh no I I agree with
you and in fact you know
indicting heads of state you know as war
criminals has problems because it means
you cannot make a deal with them yes and
and often in order to end a conflict in
a country yeah you have to um you know
you have to give the losing side some
assurance that it won't be prosecuted
that if they're G if they're gonna lose
if they're gonna lose everything yeah
yeah that they can just go away quietly
yeah yeah but if they're going to lose
everything not only their power their
privileges but but their reputation and
their their freedom and everything what
what incentive do they have to do any
deal yeah yeah no I think it was uh
Edith Hamilton the Great American uh um
classicist of the early mid 20th century
who wrote that not to think tragically
is to Rob life of its significance
um so tragic thinking is inherent in any
serious
statesmanship and we saw that you know
put to good use in some of three of my
favorite Statesmen uh you know in the
second half of the 20th century um
George Schulz James Baker and Henry
Kissinger who all you know had a very
you know tragic world view but all did
you know all did a lot of good Schulz
you know you know Schulz stood up for
human rights in Africa at the same time
he was enabling the hellsinki process in
um in uh in central eastern Europe um
you know Baker was integral to the
success of the first Gulf War and
Kissinger of course by moving over to
China in order to balance against Russia
and then nevertheless having day taunt
with Russia uh you know you know
indicates that it's not so much a
pessimistic worldview it's just a
worldview that realizes that things are
not going to be perfect and sometimes
you have to select the Lesser
evil yeah and that conflict between
goods and lesser evils or goods and
goods is permanent I guess that's what I
mean that's I mean not that any
particular conflict is
permanent uh but that that situation
we're in is a is a is a a permanent
situation it would exist Robert I think
even if there was I'm not sure it would
be desirable a world government because
if there was a world government
somewhere it would have to decide what
to do with
Rebels it would have to decide if one
country in that had hitherto been
independent rebelled against the world
government it would be like a gigantic
Roman Empire what would they do they
would have to suppress them or do deals
with them they'd have to do something to
preserve the
order yes um well in any case we should
never have a world government because a
world government by Def by definition
would be very oppressive absolutely
there would be an assumption that
everyone agrees on the basic modes of
order and politics Etc which of course
people never it's not the case it's not
the case yeah it's not the case the
world government by definition has to be
oppressive but what we can move towards
is maybe more of a a form of world
governance um you you know with with
major your powers um but we're not there
yet I mean you know we have an
Antiquated un where countries like India
are not represented but a country like
France is you know you on the security
Council I mean so that um you know we we
don't have the procedures in place um um
to you know you know to make a
difference as much is I think what we're
seeing in Ukraine is that it's all about
interest and power I mean the United
States is the biggest military power in
the world it has a self-interest in
seeing Ukraine you know win but not not
win overwhelmingly totally so as to
bring down Putin and Russia but to win
essentially to show that you know to
show that invasions of that sort will
fail you know um so and and you know and
as I said earlier I think the Biden
Administration in its own
non-intellectual way has been thinking
you know been thinking you know
tragically about it in a constructive
manner in other words they want Ukraine
to win but they're afraid of a
catastrophic victory that would lead
that would lead to chaos or or something
unpredictable in
Moscow I think one factor which will
play very importantly in that it looks
as if it might even be being considered
now is that the impact of the Ukraine
war so far has been millions of
refugees I don't know 3 to five million
or something going to different
countries to Poland and
elsewhere um the impact of a Russian
collapse could be twice that
many and that really I mean it's a part
of what you were talking about earlier I
mean if if if there was a catastrophic
Victory a victory which crippled the
Russian state which you know may not be
that strong anyway uh uh at this time um
uh and there was a rerun of what
happened in 1919 and um multiple Civil
Wars and so on and conflicts between
mercenary groups I read somewhere by the
way that some people think that there
might be up to
30 semi-private mercenary groups in
Russia at the moment not just the Vagner
one but other smaller imagine the lid
coming off that and what what that would
mean it would mean among other things uh
an aspect of interconnectedness which uh
is great much greater now than it was um
in the 19th century or the early 20th
century colossal waves of migration into
Europe and elsewhere and that surely
that Prospect is one of the things that
is possibly even weighing in the mind
weighing in the mind of Poland and and
possibly even the United States and
France and others that are war of a
catastrophic Victory yes uh indeed um
always remember that Russia is much more
weakly
institutionalized than China uh were Xi
Jinping to get sick tomorrow or be
incapacitated the Chinese have a
bureaucratic mechanism that's fairly
transparent in order to select a new
leader now that could lead to some
turmoil it could lead to radical shift
in policy eventually but there is a
bureaucratic mechanism in place you know
to replace the leader in in China to a
degree that does not exist in Russia um
you know you know Russia it's a black
box you know uh as to what you know as
as to what can happen where Putin to be
seriously threatened um and remember we
are talking about a country with you
know tremendous amounts of both
strategic and tactical nuclear weapons
yes and I mean I think that's a very
important also a difference between the
Cold War because however hard it was to
read Soviet intentions these were large
groups of old men in suits with names
and histories that were widely known
meeting in rooms and coming to decisions
that's all gone because the Communist
part's gone the Communist part is still
there in China it's probably never been
as important as it is now as a
disciplinary mechanism what is it 95
million members something like that
absolutely enormous in Russia there
Putin shadow semi-criminal
semi uh um privatized groups and
otherwise as you say a black box so we
just don't know and one of the reasons
we may not know about the inner working
is that a lot of the interstices a lot
of the layers don't exist
anymore there are large vacuums of voids
that can be suddenly killed remember the
speculation in the west is to um uh uh
who who assassinates
whom people are assassinated in the uh
shadow of the Kremlin was it Putin or
was it someone else was it the chin what
no one
knows and I think that's a situation
which um uh um uh very much supports
your your analysis which is that the
levels of State capacity in Russia are
are much lower it may be highly coercive
they may
be adopting a kind of semi stalino
attitude to defend to descent but
there's nothing like the dep
of State capacity that exists in in
China yes and keep in mind during the
Cold War the you know nobody not breev
not kosan not andropov nobody had as
much power as Putin has
now